Quand j'étais petit , je pensais que les clopes qui auraient dans la futur, ça serait les mêmes dans le Cinquième élément (film de Luc Besson)
Mais en fait, c'est ça, des sortes de stylos... plumes
La première fois quand tu vois un mec qui fume une cigarette électronique...
Tu bloques un peu parce que on a l'impression que le mec fume un objet
Ouais !
Alors, contrairement à une clope normale, la cigarette électronique, tu peux fumer plein de goûts différents.
Cafés , des fruits , des légumes , enfin bon y'a aucune limite et il y'a même des goûts de villes.
Vous avez pas goût Montpellier ?
Non mais parce que moi je fume que du Montpellier. Vous avez pas ?
Putain !
Ils font quoi les gens qui fument du Montpellier ?
Hein, ils fument du Orléans ?
Je vais fumer du Orléans, moi ?!
J'ai une tête à fumer du Orléans ? Je me barre, je me barre du magasin !
Si tout le monde se met à fumer des cigarettes élecrtroniques,
plus jamais on pourra demander aux gens  "Est-ce que t'as du feu ?"
Ça, ça n'existera plus. Pour recharger les cigarettes électroniques, il faut un ordinateur...
Excusez-moi, est-ce que vous n'aurez pas un ordinateur ?
Euh... oui , bien sûr.
C'est triste parce qu'il y a pleins de gestes un peu stylés qu'on peut faire avec une clope...
...qu'on pourra plus faire avec une cigarette électronique.
Comme par exemple,
Tu veux une clope ? *bip vrai*
Euh, tu veux une cigarette électronique ? *bip faux*
*bip vrai*
*bip faux*
QUOI ?!
*bip vrai*
*bip faux*
Pour recharger une cigarette électronique, il faut mettre un liquide dedans.
Bon, pas de panique il paraît que c'est inoffensif.
D'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on peut lire sur le flacon.
Inoffensif
En faît, quand il y'a une tête de mort, ça veut dire que c'est bon y'a pas de problème.
Céléstin ? Qu-est-ce que tu fais ?
Euh, papa, je veux boire ça s'il te plait !
Il y'a une tête de mort dessus ?
Non !
Qu-est-ce que je vous ai dejà dit ?
Si il y'a pas de tête de mort sur les produits, ON NE BOIT PAS ! OK ? Qui veut des crêpes ?
Je suis véner' !
Personne ?
Bien !
Pour moi, avec la cigarette, tu sais que tu vais mourir sans doute d'une maladie qu'on connait.
Alors que la cigarette électronique,
c'est pas trop trop ce que va apporter comme maladie.
Du coup, qu-est-ce qu'ils vont écrire comme petit message de prévention sur les paquets de cigarettes électroniques ?
Fumer tue peut-être ! Euh, on sait pas encore vraiment, en fait.
Si ça se trouve, tous les gens qui fument des cigarette électronique, ils sont en train de donner une maladie super grave,
que peut-être on va découvrir seulement dans 10 ans !
Messieurs, après 10 ans d'étude, on a enfin découvert que la cigarette électronique...
ne provoquait pas le cancer.
Par contre, quelques effets secondaires. Hein.
Pas besoin de nous faire un dessin, je crois qu'on a tous compris.
En tout cas, on peut être rassurés. Marcus, je vois qu'on rigole. Euh, un commentaire ? Une remarque ?
Euh, non, non !
Allez, champagne pour tout le monde ! Sans alcool !
Bref, comme on ne sait pas trop, si vous voulez vraiment être sain de corps,
ne fumez ni de cigarettes, ni de cigarettes électroniques.
*Musique*
Par contre, n'hésitez pas a consommer un maximum de drogue dur ! A bientôt !